tout ce qui reste est ta signature et
nous sommes prêts à partir
[Musique]
maintenant tu es officiellement un disciple de
la promesse de Dieu bienvenue bienvenue à la promesse de Dieu
tu es à un âge où tu
es particulièrement vulnérable au mal
enquêtant ensemble pourquoi pas vous ici dans le
passé, je recourrais au plaisir de soi,
mais quand j'ai appris que c'était un
péché, j'ai aussi arrêté Cameron, votre lutte
est contre le péché d'attirance pour le même sexe,
vous faites face aux conséquences de vos
actions et  c'est moche
pourquoi est-elle si merdique je suppose que c'est
comme avoir vos propres méchants de Disney
celui-ci il ne laissera pas utiliser votre appel vous
ne semblez pas vraiment être une personne
ici nous n'avions pas le choix n'est-ce pas
[  Musique]
Je veux dire, ne pourrions-nous pas simplement partir et aller
là où il y
a pire une soirée karaoké ou vivre dans
la rue
[Musique]
Parlez-nous de cette fille que vous connaissiez de
chez vous, la première étape est que vous arrêtiez de
penser à vous-même, c'est un homosexuel.
je ne pense pas que c'est moi-même homosexuel je
ne le pense pas  Je me considère vraiment comme n'importe quoi
Je suis fatigué de me dégoûter de
moi-même
[Musique]
Tu n'aurais aucune idée de ce que tu fais